yesterday peter thiel at an event was
talking a lot about central banks and
bitcoin and his thoughts were really
interesting he basically railed against
the central banks and the u.s government
and said that he had under-invested in
bitcoin now this is fascinating because
peter for a long time has had critical
thoughts about some of the structural
issues some of the power arrangements in
the government and those central banks
but now it looks like a lot of the
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
that we've experienced over the last 18
months in the short term and longer term
over the last couple of decades is
catching up and so peter at this event
had a couple of key quotes to talk
through the first quote he said you're
supposed to just buy bitcoin i feel like
i've been under invested in it
specifically he was talking about the
idea that if you want to get exposure to
the industry buying bitcoin the blue
chip the largest asset was really going
to be that possible entrance point and
he felt like he had under-invested in it
second quote that he had here was when
he talked about the u.s federal reserve
and he said but surely the fact that
bitcoin is at 60 000 is an extremely
hopeful sign it's the canary in the coal
mine it's the most honest market we have
in the country and it's telling us that
this decrepit regime is just about to
blow up
pretty pretty dark stuff here coming
from peter and then lastly he said quote
the secret was already known by
everybody i think the answers are still
to go long maybe it's still is enough of
a secret this specifically is referring
to the fact that peter is famous for
investing when he says that he
understands a secret that maybe others
don't and so when we start to actually
look at this what we have is somebody
who's well respected in the investing
world in the technology world somebody
who's not afraid to have contrarian
thoughts or opinions saying look i think
that there is a legacy world that legacy
world has very specific structural
issues and we're starting to see some
kind of decay in the trust of that
organization but at the same time we
have this asset a decentralized digital
asset fully transparent with a
programmatic monetary policy that can't
be censored that is rising in popularity
you see that rise in popularity measured
directly by the price you have a fixed
supply asset as the us dollar exchange
price goes up that means more and more
people are demanding access to hold and
own that asset and so if we have these
two separate systems peter is basically
saying as one is able to kind of fade
away or become less important less
trusted the other will rise in
importance and so ultimately the
question is in his mind is how much of a
secret is the new system still is it
still something where there's
opportunity to actually allocate a
portion of your portfolio i tend to
think that there probably is a pretty
big opportunity so when we see somebody
like this somebody who's a co-founder of
multiple investment firms somebody who's
the co-founder of palantir and paypal
also the first investor in facebook
looking at a new piece of technology
again the strongest computer network in
the world valued at about 1.25 trillion
dollars and saying that there's still an
opportunity here i think that more and
more people will start to pay attention
there's a lot of folks who look at the
wall street in the financial world and
say oh if steve cohen stanley
druckenmiller and paul tudor jones and
others like them are all starting to
allocate that gives me career risk cover
i don't have to worry about it because
the best hedge fund managers are
starting to invest there the same thing
is true in the technology world if peter
thiel all of a sudden is starting to
invest in an asset and is coming out and
talking about it in a positive light
there's a lot of people who say well if
it's good enough for him it's good
enough for me and they'll start to
allocate to the asset as well they'll
start to hold it in their funds or
personally and so ultimately i think
this is a net positive for the industry
i think it's a net positive for the
asset itself but it's very interesting
to see especially that quote where he
says that he believes that this is
telling us that the decrypt regime is
about to blow up now peter in the past
has been very critical of other
administrations he's also been very
critical of other types of regime
changes and sometimes those things have
actually come to fruition
other times they haven't sometimes even
he's been correct about what he thought
was going to happen but he wasn't
actually positioned to benefit
financially as much as he wanted and so
to see him again saying hey there is
this message that maybe we are headed to
a place that we don't want to go but i'm
under invested to benefit from it might
be a canary in the coal mine that a lot
of people start to pay attention to